whatever life's throwing at you I ask
people look in the mirror and say did I
live by my values today am I proud of
the person that sat in front of me the
end of the day go out and just look at
the sky and be happy you know don't get
so heavy that you're so analytical you
strangle yourself that's
counterproductive in this episode of
Deep dive I'm joined by Professor Steve
Peters Steve is a world-renowned
psychiatrist who's dedicated himself to
understanding how the human mind works
he's worked with Elite athletes like the
Olympic cyclist sir Chris and Victoria
Pendleton five times nuker world
champion Ron O Sullivan as well as the
England football team to help them
overcome mental barriers and optimize
their performance my job is to help you
to understand how your mind is
functioning what will work best for you
but it's your job to try out and do the
work and get the emotional skills my job
is to Mentor you with that and he's
perhaps best known for his first book
The chimp Paradox which has sold
millions of copies all around the world
now in case you're unfamiliar with the
book The chimp Paradox presents this
mind management model that's based
around three fundamental forces that are
in our brains firstly we've got the
chimp which is sort of the emotion more
emotional more Primal part of our brain
that acts subconsciously and without our
explicit consent secondly we've got our
inner human which represents our more
rational more compassionate more Humane
self and thirdly we've got the computer
which is sort of the memory bank that
stores our memories and our experiences
the life's about fun as well as learning
you know it's not all about being very
therapeutic and analytical get a sense
of humor don't spend your life and then
end up you know at the end your life
looking back thinking why or why or why
whatever stage you're at in life it's
always good to stop and think hang on
let me look at the bigger
picture this season is Once Again being
sponsored very kindly by trading 212 now
people ask me all the time for
investment advice uh because they see
that I've made money and I've made
videos talking about where I'm investing
that money the thing that Warren Buffett
and basically everyone who's sensible in
the space recommends which is to invest
in Broad stock market index funds which
you can do completely for free using
trading 212 trading 212 is a fantastic
app that lets you invest in stock stocks
and shares and funds in a commission
free fashion and they've got a bunch of
features which are really helpful which
is why I personally use trading 212 to
manage a portion of my portfolio so
firstly they've got this great pies and
auto invest feature so if you're
interested in potentially getting into
investing what you can do is you can
browse the different pies that different
people have created on the platform so
you might get like a hedge font Trader
who's gone onto the platform and has
created a pie of Investments having done
a bunch of research and stuff and that
pie might be like I don't know 20% Apple
20% Tesla 10% this 10% that but it
generally way more complicated than that
and you can see the performance of that
particular pie of stocks and shares and
funds and then if you want to copy that
pie into your own account you can just
copy and paste it directly in and then
you can invest any amount of money and
it will automatically split it according
to the allocation in the P so if you
wanted to just play around with £100 and
you were like okay that P looks good it
will split out that £100 based on the
allocations of the pi which is pretty
sick they've also recently added support
for multicurrency accounts now this is
really helpful because for example if
you invest in the S&P 500 which is a
us-based Index Fund then you won't get
hit with all the various foreign EX
exchange fees if for example you're
investing from the UK like I do and if
you have an invest or an Isa account
then trading 212 also gives you daily
interest on your uninvested cash in
pounds or Euros or Us dolls so if any of
that sounds up your straight then do
please hit the link in the video
description or in the show notes and
that will let you sign up to trading 212
and if you use that link you will also
get a completely free share up to the
value of100 so it's literally free money
so you might as well so thank you so
much trading 212 for sponsoring this
episode this episode is very excitingly
brought to you by hu I've been a paying
customer of hu since 2017 since my fifth
year of medical school and it's
absolutely fantastic for those occasions
when you need a meal but you don't have
the time to necessarily cook for
yourself now these are some of my
favorite product that hu offers this is
the ready to drink which is a meal in a
bottle and each meal is 400 calories
with 22 g of protein which is pretty
reasonable and each serving has 26
vitamins and minerals as well heal ready
to drink is made from natural
ingredients like tapioca sunflower seed
coconut pea protein flax seed and hemp
seed protein it is 100% vegan like all
heuel meals and it's gluten-free and
lactose free with no Animal product and
no GMOs and heu ready to drink comes in
eight different flavors including
strawberries and cream and iced coffee
caramel along with the classics like
chocolate and vanilla now these are
widely available in supermarkets and
Corner shops and petrol stations all
around the UK but the best way to get
them is online and so if you're like me
and you have a fairly busy life where
you don't necessarily have time to cook
or make the time to cook then you might
like to try out hu ready to drink also
if you haven't yet heard the episode of
Deep dive with the founder of hu Julian
Hearn you might like to check that out
but if you'd like to give heel a try
then head over to heal.com deepdive and
that link is available in the video
description and show notes as well and
that link firstly helps me out but it
will also give you a free t-shirt and a
Shaker and so you can check out heel
ready to drink and you can also check
out the other products that they offer
so thank you so much heel for sponsoring
this episode this episode is sponsored
by kajabi and they've actually got
something really valuable for all of our
Deep dive listeners now if you haven't
heard of kajabi it's basically a
platform that helps creators diversify
their revenue with courses and
membership sites and communities and
podcast and coaching tools so it's one
of the best places for creators and
entrepreneurs to build a sustainable
business we started using kajabi ear
earlier this year and as soon as we
started using it we were like oh my God
why haven't we been using this product
for the last 3 years it's got everything
you'd possibly need for running an
online course or hosting an online
community or building an online coaching
business and it essentially makes it
really easy to run your entire online
business from payments to marketing
tools to analytics kajabi has everything
that we creators need all in one place
and actually you don't necessarily need
a huge audience to generate a
sustainable income a Creator on kajabi
can for example make $100,000 by
converting just 350 customers a year
depending on your price points and in
fact there are creators on the platform
that are making millions of dollars
every year with fewer than 100,000
followers across the social media
platforms we've been using kajabi to
host all of our online courses since the
start of 2023 from our $1 part-time
YouTuber foundations to help people
start off on their YouTube Journey all
the way up to our $5,000 package for the
part-time YouTuber accelerator which
gives you access to me and my team and
kajabi does not take any cut of what you
earn creators keep and own everything
the way kajabi makes money is through
the monthly subscription fee and even
though we generate like literally
millions of dollars every year from
kajabi we're still only paying them a
couple hundred a year and actually in
their lifetime kajabi have paid out over
$6 billion dollar to creators that's
billion with be and over a thousand
creators have become millionaires
through products on the platform now
back in May 2023 I did a keynote at a
kajabi in real life kajabi Heroes Event
in Austin Texas and in that keynote I
talked about the exact steps that I used
to grow my business from zero to over
$2.5 million per year from course
Revenue alone now people paid for the
pretty expensive tickets to watch this
keynote at the kajabi hero live event
but as an exclusive deal for deep dive
listeners kjab we have very kindly
offered to provide the recording of that
keynote completely for free to anyone
who listens to this podcast so if you're
interested in getting completely free
access to that keynote just head over to
kajabi.com Ali that's kajabi.com Ali and
that'll be linked in the show notes in
the video description as well you just
enter your email address and then you
will get the recording of that keynote
completely for free whether or not you
ever become a kajabi customer so thank
you so much to kajabi for sponsoring
this episode so Steve welcome to the
podcast um you've been a psychiatrist
for the last 30 years and you've worked
with all sorts of people from all walks
of life through your work in the NHS
people with personality disorders all
the way through to kind of high
performers in all in all areas of life
so I I guess one question I'd like to
start with is what are the biggest
misconceptions that distinguish the top
performers from I guess the average
performers I think people think there's
a magic formula there may be I haven't
seen it there are certain personality
types are certain behaviors that lead to
success and I haven't found that I think
I've met all types of personalities and
all types of approaches so for me and I
these are just personal opinions um I
think that what works is when the person
resonates with whatever approach or
method they're doing in other words they
get themselves into the right place the
right environment and approach things
the way they want to that leads to
success so but I don't think it's the
other way around saying he's a process
follow that process and it lead to
success ah okay so when it comes to the
work that you do with top performers how
do you you go about because I guess
you've worked with like the England
football team and like you know
professional cyclists and things like
that how how do you go about I guess
improving someone's performance who's
already performing at a really high
level okay so I know I'm being s of
typical psychiatrist I won't improve
their performance they will so it's very
important that we keep the terminology
otherwise if somebody came to me and
said I want you to get me to get a gold
medal at the Olympics then we stop and
say that's not what's going to happen
that's not my job uh my job is to help
you to understand how your mind is
functioning uh what will work best for
you but it's your job to try it out and
do the work and get the emotional skills
my job is to Mentor you with that so
when you say what would I do what's my
Approach my Approach is to talk to the
person and ask them what it is they're
trying to achieve what they think will
make it happen what's stopping them so
you know is if they said right
procrastination stops then we would look
at procrastination if they said
self-confidence stops me we' look at
that if it's worrying too much so it's
very specific to the individual so I
feel my job when I meet someone for the
first time is to get a background feel
for them get a feel for where they're at
what they're trying to achieve what's
happened in their life previously yeah
so I like to get what we'd call in the
trade of functional analysis you know
what's all the influences and how are
they manage them what's their approach
so I always try and simplify things so
people can follow it and I say what's
your behaviors what's your thinking what
are your emotions doing doing that's my
Triad so thinking behaviors emotions and
then I look at things that affect so
again I'm taking extremes to drive the
point but you look at your childhood you
might see you know what were your
parents like what was it imprinted upon
you you know about how you approach life
what are the values what's your culture
you know because I meet people from
different backgrounds so I need to know
their cultural background uh lots of
impact things so it is like really
delving in to pick out the the really
important factors and then get that
person to explore that and say now in
that setting what is your mind going to
do and what are you going to do and I
make an emphasis there that your mind
and you are different I always keep
saying please remember you're a
scientifically that's what I felt hit me
like an epiphany in the
1990s uh working with patients I thought
I'm talking to a mind and I'm talking to
a patient they were different and that's
where I think for me the way I practice
medicine it
changed the mind and you are different
yes interesting okay so this Triad of
thoughts behaviors and emotions yeah I
imagine when you're like if for example
you get introduced to the England
football team and you know like and then
you start asking them about this sort of
the the functional analysis
stuff are they surprised like is that
what they're expecting when when they
when they have a conversation with you I
think the expectation is different for
different uh players so some will come
in and and give you performance issues
and they'll say things like you know I'm
lacking confidence so uh not just
England football but um any sports
person in a team often a team player
might say I tend to start losing
confidence and hide or they might say I
fear the crowd or they might say I fear
making a mistake so they would bring
that to the table whereas other people
uh in Elite Sport don't want to talk
about performance issues they want to
talk about personal um like self-esteem
or they want to talk about
relationships uh and they might bring
family Dynamics and or you know their
own self-image might come into it yeah
so it's I don't have I don't go in with
an idea of saying this is what we'll
cover I've got to ask the person what's
what do you want from me and make sure I
can deliver it um but if you look as my
specialty area is the human mind and how
it functions it really doesn't matter
what they bring to me will end up going
down that road nice so your um your book
The Chim Paradox is absolutely like
world famous
um I wonder if we can if I can ask you
what's the what's the Mind model that
you introduce in the book and then we'll
kind of going back yeah to the 1990s
what happened is um that was an epiphany
moment and it was with the particular
patient so I won't go into the great
detail but just to say that I was a a by
just asking the right questions to talk
to what I thought was a very sensible
person and then suddenly someone who
didn't seem sensible at all and was very
emotional and pretty catastrophic in
thinking so I started looking at what do
because we've now got functional MRI
scanners what does the the research show
us on this and I started realizing that
if we scan somebody's brain and they
were talking as what I'd called a human
being they were rational they were
logical so I'm going to simplify the
Neuroscience CU I realized a lot of
listeners are not neuroscientists we
looked at the top part of your head the
dorsal lateral prefrontal cortex seem to
be leading on this and this we know is
where executive functioning takes place
so in essence if you put your oxygen
supply in that part of your brain you're
going to think and work in a certain way
yeah you look for facts logic but
there's a more to it that hit me that
part of the brain works with acceptance
and starts saying it is what it is that
part of the brain looks for
Solutions as opposed to when I started
moving the patient by asking emotive
questions so things that would make them
upset or more emotional if you look at
functional scanners what'll happen
they'll go to the orbit of frontal
cortex just above your eyes and now they
start acting in a very strange way they
wouldn't work with facts at all in fact
they'd have great difficulty accepting
them so what they do is go on feelings
I'm not saying they're wrong and
intuition and they'll work with those
and they won't understand facts it's
almost like facts are not part of the
vocabulary so what you've got to I
started to see is I've got two people in
the room or two brains in the room so
then I start looking and think well how
can I understand this better and that
became two systems so then I looked and
I thought you see classic Connections in
the brain so when the orbit of frontal
works it pulls on things like the
amygdala heavily um all of the brain to
me is like an orchestra so both of these
systems pull on the brain but they
select certain of the instruments and
the orbit frontal selects feelings past
experience emotion it works on trigger
points it works on behaviors so this is
behavioral therapies coming in and then
I looked at the dorsal lateral areas and
they know work with behaviors they work
with rationality and thinking so your
cognitive therapies are coming
in nice and that I thought oh this is
really good but there's more to the
brain than that so
in the
center uh you've got all this other sort
of instruments playing away they're not
the lead instruments they're not the
orchestral conductors which is what
these two other parts are they're the
thinkers but they actually contribute
heavily so I started seeing that as
being a
computer so what I'd got is the center
of the brain was a computer advising but
it does more than advise we may get to
this uh it actually takes over so there
was a paradox that when you imprint a
belief in that computer the two thinkers
are going to be the decision makers y
have to listen to that they can't go
against it okay so for example if you
had a belief that this building was on
sound and the roof is about to collapse
then whether you think emotionally or
rationally you have to get out of the
building y you know so the center of
your brain it was crucial that it seemed
blank at
Birth part from instincts and drives
it's blank belief systems start coming
in and we work the out from being taught
or experience so I started think we can
alter that and that would alter whether
you left the building or not on your
belief yeah so this all got complicated
as he's doing and I thought this got to
be made simple now I teach at Sheffield
medical school and teaching medical
students um they like things simple and
practical as I do and I'm thinking these
are doctors to be and they're not going
to be neuroscientists they're going to
be many of them GPS and other careers in
medicine but they want understanding of
what the patients are thinking and how
they they act and how they can work with
that and so I then had another Epiphany
MH I started looking at people and
thinking when they're irrational they
looked just like
chimpanzees I looked at chimpanzees and
thought they have a society which is
very similar not everything is is in
line but I started speaking to the
homedy Specialists people who knew the
aps but more important the ones were the
neuroscientists looking at the APS and
at that point I was told and I believe
them the chimpanzee and the human have
the same system in their brain when
we're reacting emotionally so but the
other Apes don't so we think in a
certain way now this has been published
20 years on in 2018 they published this
to say the other great apes the gorilla
rang a Tang bonobo they don't think like
humans and chimpanzees but we are so
close that we say this is our is
relative y because we think the way they
think genetically it's not our nearest
relative the bonobos got more genes um
so I just coined the phrase I said to
the students if I said you had a little
Chimp in your head and when you're in
this part of your brain that's the chimp
brain they loved it it was simple so
when you be become irrational or your
mind takes over that part of brain works
with trigger points behaviors is
impulsive catastrophic it's a defense
system yep whereas when you move to the
dorsal lateral areas you're in human
mode now it's you but what what was
intriguing is I was getting this with
patients and then there was this moment
for again for me in Epiphany probably
around just the late
90s there was no control over the orbit
of frontal it was very fast moving and
it's a reactive system and it's inbuilt
and you're given it and when you look at
the development of the brain it has a
head start in the fetus so it's already
operating in fetal life and it keeps
going right through yep a whole of our
life uh whereas the human part as I'm
calling it didn't operate so we come
late to the party so I started then
looking at Child Development and I found
that it's obvious it became blatant that
children around two or three start
saying why and the dors lateral areas
are coming in with reasoning before that
they don't ask it's behavioral y so for
example if you want to help a child
that's distressed distract it y you know
and we know that works best don't reason
with it because you can't reason so so
this all started coming together and I
thought I've got to keep it simple so
the students helped me they wouldn't let
me go complex so they said right you've
got a human brain which is you have you
are in control of that and that's logic
rational calm and solution finding you
got a chimp bra in which you've been
given at Birth yep and that's why at the
beginning of this I said that's your
mind it's a machine you don't have a say
in it research shows that for most of us
we're on the neurotic type Spectrum our
chip system is highly strong and it's
quite reactive and impulsive but there's
a spectrum some people have very
quiescent calm chimps uh and I always
say to people if you're got a calm chimp
it may seem an advantage but actually in
the long run it's a negative because
it's meant to be highly reactive it's
meant to give you warning of danger yeah
uh and that going back to your point
about um Sports people or or anybody it
can be your best friend because that
thing's outside the box and reacts quick
and warns you of danger and we know our
intuitive skills research shows are far
more accurate than when we have to try
and find logic and facts initially so
working with intuition as long as it's
functioning well is actually a massive
plus so you have to start joining forces
of two thinking brains and start working
together and again the research shows
the people who work with both the logic
and the intuition and learn how to
manage them and emotional warning
signals from the chimp system do the
best nice this is really complex I'm no
this this is a great explanation um I'm
just sort of okay so the the human brain
is the dorsal the dorsal lateral
prefrontal cortex the well it's that's
the lead and then it has all the system
in the computer helping it okay right so
that's the chimp has it system the orbit
frontal and it has an entire system
working for it the thing is that when
the chimp Brin looks to the computer for
advice it also listens to the human
system and when the human listens it
listens to the chimp system got so they
both have input into the computer but
the chimp can put some really unhelpful
things in so we have unhelpful beliefs
appear unhelpful behaviors and we have
to learn how to recognize and how to
remove them or if we can't remove them
manage them interesting okay yeah so as
you were saying that I was thinking that
I I think I think I have a fairly
quiescent Chimp in most most areas and
that most most of my friends would would
call me like hyper rational and some
some would say as as a compliment others
would say it as uh absolutely the
opposite and so what that means is that
you know I'll be in a situation where
I'm in turkey with some friends and some
guy is like offering us a thing and I'm
like oh he's probably very friendly he's
a nice enough Chap and then my friends
are like dude this is like bad vibes
like what the hell like this guy's TR
clearly trying to scam us and I I just
did not pick up on that intuitively and
I was thinking oh no it's probably
reason I mean yeah I can I can
understand why he's doing this thing and
it's been helpful in some areas where
having a quiescent Shimp means I'm
totally chill making YouTube videos and
public speaking and I don't have a lot
of fears that people have with that but
it also does mean that I don't pick up
on int intuitive cues that can protect
protect me from danger and that's
perfect I mean that's a really good
example where like said at the beginning
that we you have to you have to learn
about your brain and say right this
system I've been given is really calm
and collected so I'm not probably going
to suffer with this pulsive trigger
reactions that a lot of people get and
you may or may not wake up in the night
panicking and having imposter syndrome
which a lot of The highr Chimps get
although it's fairly Universal um but
you have to then say right I'm my
chimp's a bit naive and it's a bit too
trusting so you have to then learn and
program your computer to say right stop
you know if I'm in a vulnerable position
so it's quite interesting you mention
holiday because we know that certain
settings leave you vulnerable so parties
holidays um new environments new people
you're much more vulnerable than when
you're in your home setting uh and home
territory and familiar routines there
it's much easier to be on guard whereas
if we're taking off guard uh hence
holiday romances you know and hence like
you say somebody comes up and says
please help and you're taken offu and
because you're in a holiday type mood uh
you could end up in trouble that's
interesting yeah one of the one of the
rules that we've come up with as a way
of managing me within my team is that
whenever I'll go whenever I go to a
conference in America I get like grandio
thingies and like yeah I want to grow my
business to like you know 10x and 20x
like let's do it and so all the team has
realized is that we have a 72h hour
button that whenever I come up with a
new idea they press the 72 hour button
and we pause on it for 3 days and if I'm
still excited about it then we'll then
we'll think about it and there's been so
many occasions where the team has been
like I'd like to invoke the 72 hour
button here we've paused and 3 days
later I forgotten that I was EXC excited
about the thing because it was you know
as much as I like to think I'm rational
as like in those contexts where there's
like adrenaline and people around me and
sort of this R atmosphere that's that's
common in in the US that will then take
over so I guess it's the the naive chimp
let me use that as a as an example a
generic on it's really good um so I'm
working with you and you say right this
is what I do Steve and and I now I'm not
going to tell you to wait three days I'm
not going to do that what I would do now
is ask you if you didn't wait 3 days and
were impulsive and it did go wrong would
you be saying I'm glad I did it because
I think that's what life's about you
know you jump in if you start drowning
you swim uh and I think that's exciting
and I love that then I'm hardly going to
advise you to wait three days because
you've told me I like that kind of
lifestyle and I feel I can deal with it
whereas if you say if I made a mistake I
wouldn't deal with this very well then
be saying okay well what advice do you
WR you'll give yourself and then you'll
say wait three days so in other words
you work this out yeah you have I don't
tell you I can't tell you because I
don't know what you'll deal with what I
might do if you said I like to just jump
in and I like to drown and I like to
swim and I and then I work with you and
think actually you're lacking Insight
because that's not the case because what
you do is when you start realizing
You've Gone In Too Deep you have
restless nights you make yourself ill
you you Partners or friends start saying
to you oh you you know you're irritable
and and now your decision making is
going off then I have to say look
although you decided that you're this
kind of person actually we need to give
you some insight it's not actually true
it's not getting the best out of you and
I give you evidence based yep so and
then again you have to make a decision
I'm not going to say it to you right
change yep so that's why it's hard when
people say to me and I get these
interviews right give us five tips for
the listeners or readers
and and I always try and warn host who
interviewing I'm not going to do it yeah
because I can't what I can do is give
you generic things and say common sense
is so we've talked about the
neuroscience and obviously this is my
feeli unbiased so if you then said well
what is your aim then and I explained
that I'd do the analysis my aim would be
to give Common Sense questions and say
if you are in a good place at the start
of the day yeah so you're at peace with
yourself you're in a positive frame of
mind and happy and quite an accepting
what's the chance you'll go through the
day and do well as opposed to being in a
bad place yeah it's common sense and
self-evidence that most people say well
been in a good place you know I have had
challenges I've had people saying no I
think being in a bad place makes you
fight more and you know and then I have
to work with that yeah I'll challenge it
and say let's keep checking because it's
common sense that if you can get your
mind and yourself in a really good Place
yeah the chances are you'll be much more
functional what I'm not advocating is
that people become robots people often
say what we have to do is kill the chimp
and I'm saying no the chimp gives the
absolute flavor color excitement driving
your life okay I'm saying I'm saying
work with it but recognize its strengths
and its weaknesses which are unique to
you everyone's unique yeah and that's I
think one of the reason when I started
did medicine that psyche became a
something I enjoyed because I never knew
who would come through the door yeah
every life was different and I love
getting the flavor of whether the're you
know famous people or not I anybody's
the same yeah it's great yeah I love the
thing around um you know this is the the
thesis behind my book as well which is
coming out in a few months Feelgood
productivity where we just Dove a lot
into the evidence that does show that
like when you feel good when you've got
the positive emotions you're more
creative you're more productive you're
less stressed um broaden and build
Theory and all this all this sort of
stuff um and so I feel like that's how
I've been you know I've been making
YouTube videos for the last six years
some like partly in medical school
partly while while working as a doctor
and people kept on asking how are you so
productive how you how do you do all
this stuff and a lot of it was around
making sure the thing felt enjoyable and
I felt comfortable doing it and I felt
at peace which involved combating you
know initially imposter syndrome and
procrastination and she did get it fear
of judgment and like oh what I had this
negative comment and it's like there's
100 positive comments but the one
negative comment I'm going to fixate on
that and then learning strategies to
kind of cope with that over time and
again you know if I'd make you that
point and you said this is what I've got
and I've got imposter syndrome and I say
well the first thing is see it as a very
positive thing it's very positive
imposter syndrome it's not negative um
if you see what the brain's doing all
it's saying is can you check for me so I
said this is this is the chimp at its
best to me so if you get impostor
syndrome the chimp brain is sending you
a message to say look my job isn't to
find Solutions that's your job right as
the human you find me the solution I'll
give you the the warning I'm doing my
job are you an imposter so your job is
to say thanks for the warning let's have
a look at what I'm trying to do and now
depending on the person you might want
to look at things like am I articulate
am I doing the job well do I get out of
my guests on the podcast do I get the
information the public want you could go
down that route or you could say I'm not
going to go down that route because I
don't know what the public will say and
let's be honest that the most vocal
people are the negative ones so you will
get a distorted um statistic you might
go down a different route and say let me
look at my values am I doing what I
think is genuine and if I reach 10
people doing this is that more important
to me than reaching a million who
actually don't move anywhere so again I
would work with you to say let's look at
the impostor syndrome let's pick it up
as a positive let's give it an answer
let's give it a solution and then let's
work with it it so then it becomes a
positive productive thing not a
negative I was interviewing a clinical
psychologist yesterday um and we were
talking about the idea of uh holding
thoughts at arms length and like not
like overidentifying with them so I'm an
imposter I guess if we over identify
with it and we view it as like the truth
becomes quite hard to to act but if we
be like okay thank you thank you for the
warning I'll take that into account
treat it with with lightness then can I
guess take into account the information
from the chimp appreciate and thank the
chimp yeah but choose to act I think the
difference is that it's the same it's
just different models but uh what I'm
saying is if I look at the newos signs
the orbit of frontal area is is trying
to give you information but in an
emotional way because the only way it
can communicate is to disturb you that's
its job is to disturb you and that gets
your attention so if you listen and use
it correctly then it stops disturbing
you but if you don't come up with
something good enough then it disturbs
you again and says have another goal and
it keeps doing this until you come up
with an answer which satisfies it so
it's getting back to a homeostasis in
the brain it's saying we're meant to be
at peace you know but you're not doing
your job it's not the brain that's doing
wrong it's the human who's not finding
Solutions uh and that's where it is hard
and sometimes as you say we're too close
to it we start listening to the chimp
and saying maybe I'm an impostor and
this way it's great to have someone out
out side to be objective and say okay
let me ask you the right questions and
help you if you can't get an answer then
friends or a therapist or anybody might
come in and say well have you thought of
this and you think oh that's that's true
that's a different perspective so we're
not meant to be isolated as humans yeah
we never were we work as part of a team
um so I'm not advocating again that
people get into this position where
they're so uh independent of the world I
don't think that's realistic I think I'd
aim for that because it gives you
stability and peace of mind for within
yourself but the reality is that our
brains are dysfunctional they're meant
to be and so we will get thrown around
by events and that's where sometimes if
you can't get that in a piece you turn
to your friends who can provide it so
that and that's the chimp saying I the
chimp Works externally it doesn't work
internally wait what do you mean so it
looks for answers outside of itself so
it wants it wants you to provide
Solutions and it looks for stability by
friends so for example you send your
book out there and then somebody writes
a criticism right which it's going to
get right inevitable yeah uh and your
chimp brain will pick that up and panic
because it only sees the criticism and
it wants to be Lov by everybody y right
so you have to now give it rational
thinking to say look there's a hundred
people said it's good you know and the
reality is whoever writes any kind of
book They're going to get criticized and
they all was going to be some people who
love it yeah so you can rationalize it
but if the chimp's still not reassured
on that it's just not strong enough yeah
uh then your friends are the ones who
come and saying look I think it's great
and your chimp listens to that so it
listens to the people close and that's
why our friends or Partners can make us
feel good yeah cuz they're more
important than the public oh that's good
so there's a lot of rules around it and
but as you can see this is where it's a
challenge for me I can't impose that cuz
it may not be true for you and you might
be someone who says doesn't matter what
my partner or friends think but you
might have somebody who is older could
be a father mother uh or an older person
that you really respect and they give
you that stability so it's almost a
substitute parent it could be a parent
and again quite a few people work with
that paternal or maternal figure rather
than friends and partners so their
default is to get the protective
development is is that something that we
can control or change do you think like
whose opinion are chimp listens to yeah
I mean one of the features of a
therapist often is to take that role so
if we had someone who had a terrible
childhood and their parents were
critical of them um either uh in a
negative way or trying to be positive
like saying you could do better and that
sometimes is destructive um if we the
the therapist can substitute being the
parent and challenge that uh and then
the person who's receiving even the
therapy actually thinks yeah that
they've got a good point they become the
parent figure so it's quite a positive
thing to do and our mind works on that
emotional rather than rational feeling
that I've suddenly got approval from
this new parent figure and so you form
these bonds often uh professional bonds
with a therapist who represents that and
brings this in but you can do that
yourself as well you know I'm not saying
you need to run off to a therapist um so
it's IND again
individual I'm curious so it's it sounds
like you define the mind as being the
chimp part of the computer and the the
so the chimp plus computer equals mind
yeah but then the human is not like
that's not the separate well I mean it's
it's pedantic really it's just semantics
that uh the human chimp and computer are
the Neuroscience of your brain okay and
then I'm saying right but you must
understand that the chimp and the
computer are given to you at Birth y to
keep it simplified the chimp is already
programmed yep and it's going to work in
a certain way and work with emotions the
computer is more or less a blank slate
and now it's up to you and the chimp to
put beliefs in there values in the
memories interpretations of memories
okay yeah got it you do all that but can
you go back and modify it yes you can
take out the unhelpful beliefs the
Gremlins I call them and recognize them
the only thing I did feel when I started
developing the model in the early 2000s
is sometimes I've seen therapists
obviously my work is teaching uh whether
they're doctors or psychologists nursing
staff um they'll try and change
something which has damaged the system
so for example if you've had a really
bad experience as a child sometimes we
know that neuroscientifically it's
almost like you've got damaged to the
Circuit so it's like a computer with a
virus that we just can't get it out so
what we do is contain it so sometimes I
say to people you've got to recognize
when it's not really a gremlin it's more
I called a goblin where you think we
can't remove this it's a bit of damage
but can contain it and work with it
otherwise again I'm giving a dramatic
example if you wanted everyone to be um
independent and and their self-esteem to
be high I don't think that's possible I
think some of us need other people and
we have a default that I I do need
people around me yeah so don't make me
independent because it won't happen so I
I think again it's learning what do we
have to live with and what scarred us a
little bit and what can we change over
and think no that's something I can
rethink nice so while we're here like um
what is the Goblin and Gremlin and how
did you arrive at those kind of like
quite like high high imagery kind of
yeah so the commonest one which I I
mentioned is first of all the Gremlins
The Gremlins are just beliefs or
behaviors they're really unhelpful and
we've just got into a routine pattern so
you've formed these Pathways in your
brain and they keep repeating and
repeating and they drive you crazy
because you don't want them uh so can we
turn them over yes but There are rules
about how you turn them over so often
the one of the rules is we have a belief
is usually underpinned by five six seven
other beliefs so I always say these are
the Gremlins these beliefs don't dance
alone they're a gang and you got to pin
all of them so I go around and find all
the supporting Gremlins and then we
knocked them all on the head one by one
if you do that and then you must replace
them with what I call the autopilot
that's a really truthful not a false
belief a truthful belief based on f
facts and logic and that will form a new
pathway and we keep reinforcing that
till eventually and it's not
brainwashing it's reality bringing you
to reality the Gremlins Go and you think
over time yeah they've gone and it can
be instant or it can be over
weeks the goblin is different and the
one I usually use is the fridg door
syndrome which a lot of us relate to uh
when children first go to school they're
asked to paint a picture Y and and take
it home and Mom or Dad approves and
sticks it on the fridge door what Mom
and Dad often do then is say on clever
and they're pointing to the picture
saying you know you're so clever clever
girl clever boy I love you I want the
world to see we'll put it on the fridge
door
and that's damaged that's a
goblin yeah that's really bad news why
is that bad news right it's really bad
news you you have to step back and see
how a child thinks at this point because
they're not fully rational they're
mainly in ship mode yeah and what you've
really said to the child is if you bring
something to me that you've done that I
approve of oh y yeah then I love you and
the world knows and I'm going to make
sure the world knows I'm going to really
emphasize it on the fridge door now I'm
saying it dramatically to drive the
point but if you did it differently and
you said well put the picture down when
a child came home and say I want to see
it not yet and you sat them on your knee
and said I love you as you are I think
you're great I want the world to know
you're great and then you say to the
child what's this you can still approve
of the picture you can also see oh well
the sun isn't green is it and with the
child doing that what you find is the
child begins to form resilience because
it learns that I am valued as me as a
person I don't need to prove myself to
me or anybody else what I can do is I
can p a picture and I can self criticize
so the child can laugh at something if
you think it's very subtle the question
is does it work and the answer is yes
research shows that if you start
building resilience in children by
giving them the power of uh
self-criticism both good and bad uh they
learn to do that as teenagers and it
gives them resilience against peer
pressure 10 years later so the evidence
is if we work with children it will work
um would it work on an adult so if we
were now I call myself a fridge door
child so I've been in uh impregnated
with this belief at the age of five and
I can't get away from it and now I just
want to keep make sure I don't get wrong
and I'm terrified which imposter
syndromes based on of getting things
wrong can I turn it over yes you can
once you start recognizing it you can
start saying actually I'm not a
5-year-old I don't need parents approval
I need my approval and I might shift my
system now from Chimp to human and say
I'm going to work with my
values you know now we're into much more
powerful territory because values will
give you piece of Mind whereas producing
a good picture want it'll give you
temporary relief but we know that that
your chimp brain will lens say it's it's
not good enough and it'll compare what
you did yesterday with today and it's
never favorable so so there's a there's
a trap here and it's getting through to
that subtle trap that if you keep
working with that system and you don't
know it you can't find peace of mind
it's always temporary whereas if you
shift systems you suddenly think I've
got it now I'm bringing perspective in
you know I'm bringing values in the
system shifts uh I can give you a an
anecdote
of someone I worked with who heard the
frar syndrome and came to me and said
well we're just about to find our first
child as a man and he said he won't be
fridge door and time passed cut the
story short six years later she came he
said went to the first parents evening
we was so elated because the teacher
said why can't they all be like him and
he said um he wasn't bothered he'll have
got anything because he's self-concerned
and his value is within himself and he's
a happy child now that may be just
coincidence but he was adamant it was we
did not give him the Frid door syndrome
um I was only sort of like Ping my
feathers thinking that was good until he
said it actually works what you do I
thought well I hope it does I spend my
life doing it so but yeah but it's a
good example that a lot of us are
fridged door and we're worried about
what people think and even criticize
ourselves so we become our own worst
critic yeah this reminds me of um Alfie
con's book unconditional par ing okay
basically talks about and he's got
another book called uh punished by
rewards and his whole thesis for he's a
child psychologist his whole thing is
like praise is actually really damaging
for kids yeah because of this thing of
like you know 5-year-old Johnny thinks
oh I am loved when I get good grades
that's it that's it that's why I
remember fridge door the whole thing I
love the fridge the fridge door thing it
makes so much sense I think just to
relate that to something something in my
life I think in the early days of I
think I I was very much a fridge door
child as well where it's like you know I
got 98% an exam it's like why isn't it
100% kind kind of thing um and a lot of
my time in secondary school
was trying desperately to retain my cuz
you know in the in the 11 plus I got
like top of the cohort I was like oh my
God I need to retain my position cuz I
wanted to go to Medicine I wanted to go
to Cambridge it's like my entire
identity was wrapped up in retaining
this academic status and then I got to
medical school and I'm like uh oh I'm
bang average here like this is this is
this is dangerous um and but that's
emphasizing the point
you know I've put him on the books I I
worked obviously a privilege to work
with with sports people I'm not a sports
fan uh but I'm a people fan and so it's
been great to go to multiple Olympic
games but I remember walking around the
Olympic Village at one of them uh with
someone who didn't get a gold medal they
got medal but it wasn't gold and I conso
them and I just thought this is
ridiculous you know step back you know
even getting to the Olympics is
phenomenal but it's that power of the
chimp and as a principle whatever the
people are watching listening to this uh
you've got to step back and say is this
in my life where no matter what I do
it's never good enough you know the
chimp complains or it's good enough for
that day and then it starts pulling to
bits the next day and I've seen this in
medicine obviously I've had a privilege
of gain been undergraduate Dean and
working with young people for 30 years
in in Sheffield uh and you know some of
them struggle their way through medicine
for 5 years and they desperately want to
be doctors and they say if I just get to
be a doctor and they did the graduate
they come back to me I get to know
something well uh and then they're
saying ah everyone's a doctor it's
nothing and they've dissed what they've
been working for for five years and this
is typical of how the chimp brain works
because it's always got to keep trying
to be better and prove itself yeah and I
if you conflict a human then you you
still drive yourself don't get me wrong
and you can still celebrate a medical
degree and S please but you rely back on
your values you rely back on you know
how do I feel I'm doing as a human being
what do I value yeah I can push that
point because it's interesting when
because you said he want people would
take away points um one of the commonest
things I find when people are in this
mode and they down themselves with low
self-esteem and I ask them how would
they describe their best friends and
it's a trap uh and they fall in and they
always start describing them as being
nice people or kind people people who
listen someone's got a sense of humor
reliable it's am they never start with
well he's got a degree in Business
studies he got a first class from they
don't ever say that and I'll say is that
important they say no yeah but so you
you can't be a hypocrite and then so I'm
going to use values for choosing my
friends partner uh and look at the way I
see people you can't be a hypocrite and
then flick yourself into external
achievements possessions you know I'm
not against achievement and possession
I'm just saying that they keep them in
their place and if you wearing your
friends up on values wear yourself upon
values yeah
um one of the things so when when we
emailed you before this podcast and we
asked like what would be a good result
for you you said a line that really
resonated with me it was it was it was
to the effect of as long as this helps
one person who's in a bad place then
then that's the goal yeah and that
reminded me of like you know after 3
years of making YouTube videos I I think
my chimp was very uh fixated on like the
performance of the video like the view
count and all that kind of stuff and I
realized that actually my model for
making YouTube videos now is as long as
this helps at least one person or has
the potential to help at least one
person then I'm happy yeah and that's
like takes all the pressure off it means
that even though the Mind still is like
oh you know I can't say this because
it's not quite right and like uh it's
still like know helping one person and
just that kind of thing helps me at
least just get over all of the inherent
emotional baggage associated with like
making a video putting myself out there
that's well done so and I think um again
if you're looking at the model I'm using
uh which is not for everyone but if
people resonate great um if you're in
chimp mod I promote that so I would be
saying to you if I'm working with you I
want you to look at your figures I want
you to use the chimp system to say right
because that's going to prod you into
thinking make sure this is quality but
once you've done the podcast now turn
move systems into human and say if one
person so there is a place for the Chimp
in our Our Lives it isn't that I'm
saying don't use it I'm saying I use it
in sport I want the chimp to say I'm
going to get the gold medal and the
world record I want that because that
will drive you and give you some
commitment yeah I don't need it I I can
use the human system which is commitment
the chimp is motivation so I don't work
with motivation but if people push me
because it's just in Emotion I work with
commitment cuz successful people work
with commitment so and I would then say
but by all means when you're in training
use the chimp to say this has to be a
brilliant session all I'm saying is when
You' finished switch to human and be
proud of the fact to give it everything
didn't work perfectly or it did that's
great there's another day get some
perspective then you leave your training
session in a good place because you've
flicked into a reasonable state of mind
now yeah instead of leaving thinking
that wasn't good enough I'm not going to
make it which is leaving you in the
chimp mode walking out and that's not
going to help at all it's too emotional
it's
destructive but again you know what you
experienced I did the same when I first
invented the chip model and it started
really taking off and there was a lot of
like gravity with it and I thought B me
what have I done because I'm an academic
professor and you know and my chimp was
saying you got to face your Ps and
they're going to say a chimp and a human
inside your head you know and I got to
this point where you know I saw what it
did for medical students some of them
they'd say it transforms your life you
realize it's not me this it's a machine
and I've got to manage this and I've
stopped then attacking myself and I've
unmodded myself and so I did the same
when I wrote the first book I said if 10
people write and say this has changed my
life and I've done the right thing and
if the rest of my P slate me then fine
I'm a little bit off the wall I'm a
little bit Maverick uh but I just think
uh it's not important what the public
think is important what the 10 people
think yeah um luckily more than 10 it's
been been a major success for a lot of
people so and that's again my values you
think that's what I came to do help
people and have done
it yeah cuz I guess you know even when I
was when I was writing this one um
there's you know when when talking about
like neuroscience and things there's a
lot of like simplifying that that needs
to be done and in my mind I was also
like yeah but like if someone like
follows up the references and they see
that like well you haven't mentioned the
Nuance in that study and blah blah blah
blah blah all of this sort of stuff and
it took kind of my agent and Editor to
be like hang on you're not writing this
book for an audience of like for an
academic peer review paper you're
writing it for normal people who will
find it helpful and so is if that's the
goal then we can put all the references
in the footnotes which no one's going to
read and it's like yeah there's that
that Balancing Act which I guess again
you're not I'm assuming I haven't seen
the vook but you're not purporting that
you're this expert in neuroscience and
interpretation because we don't know and
I I would say like with students
sometimes as doctors we change our mind
and the Neuroscience is moving all the
time and it's confusing and there's
contradictory research but I think the
bottom line for me is although I come me
as a neuroscientist a doctor consult
psychiatrist that's secondary need to
being a human being saying what works so
although I'm saying as a doctor I want
evidence base I'm not so tight on it I
think I've always joked about the hoy
candles if they you put them in your
ears and light them and you say it gives
me peace then light your candles you
know there's no evidence it's going to
do anything but that's not for me to say
I think it's what works for you all I
can do is say if we look at evidence
there's no evidence but it could have a
placebo effect and we know that's
powerful yeah so I wouldn't worry when
the book comes out because uh as long as
you're saying look which I've done in
mine and the new book the pass through
the jungle I tried to give them
references cuz people said where's the
evidence so there's a lot there
but I've also tried to say that you know
that's up to you read around cuz you
will get even the neuroscientists argue
but the point at the end of the day I'm
trying to do is just be practical what
works for you what's giving you better
quality of life what's making you love
yourself a bit uh and having great
relationships you know and success and
if it works then okay the evidence is
there that's that's a bonus it's you
don't work from the evidence and go the
other way yeah nice um we used the
fridge door as an example of Goblin yeah
um what are some examples of Gremlins
and like what's the distinction between
the two okay goblins uh can't be removed
so the fridge door tends to stick with
us all the time it's so ingrained it's
like a pathway in the brain that's so
fixed we have to work with it and say
okay so again I'm taking that the the
fridge door an example but you can
imagine in the world of Psychiatry uh
there's a lot of terrible life stories
you hear and some children particularly
might have been neglected abused and we
know that children who are really thrown
around for the first seven eight years
of their life often find their unstable
as adults emotionally and quite clingy
not all not all and and that's not the
child of the person that's the machine
yeah so the machine is and we we
struggle to get them to be calm and
collected and form good relationships
and I'm saying rather than try and
change the machine let's work with the
machine however when we're going through
life let's say we have a bad experience
we form a relationship which is an
intimate one and it's the first
relationship we have and the person is
dishonest with us and um betrays us uh
then we have a belief that we can form a
belief that all relationships are going
to be like this all people are not
trustworthy and it's based on that one
really severe emotional experience that
can be turned around that's a belief
you've got which is false you've just
picked the wrong person you know so you
look at phrases throughout the years
that tell us this is common experience
you kiss a lot of frogs before you find
your prince so they're telling us that
you will have some false starts and
they'll be painful you know but that
doesn't mean there isn't somebody out
there that's like you that's going to
say this means something to me and I'm
going to work on a a valued relationship
so that's a belief you've form which is
false but you're working with it and we
have to turn false beliefs into reality
and the truth okay so the false beliefs
that we form as like adults are the
Gremlins and children we can find them
as children y but a goblin is something
which is um something which is so
ingrained it's hard to shift because the
circuits have altered so we know that as
we're developing uh there are windows
for some parts of the brain to develop
and if they don't develop in the time we
expect then we find it a struggle to
change them so they've not developed
properly so we know certain areas the
brain don't reach their full potential Y
and children are abused we find certain
areas the brain don't actually grow to
the extent they're meant to and form the
connections they're meant to and that
window is lost so we know their brain
will always have a struggle and one of
them for for children for example is the
ability for one part of the brain to
dampen down emotion is lost so we know
they're far more reactive to emotional
situations and that's the machine not
being able to dampen down yep that's all
I'm saying so if we recognize that in
Neuroscience terms I give it the name
gobling see you're always going to have
that bit of overreaction so we're going
to have to program it to manage it but
it may never go so don't beat yourself
up if it happens you think us my
machine's a bit damaged got it and so
goblins and Gremlins are part of the
computer which is that sort of blank
slate yeah kind of computer model which
the human and also the chimp draw refer
to and then get guidance or advice from
awesome or it takes over if it's
programmed enough cuz it's also like the
example is the one is driving to work if
you drive to work you don't think about
it and you drive to work and I said was
there any problems you you can't recall
it so your computer's doing that but
it's in everyday conversation you meet
friends and the first thing you probably
do is say how are you doing you didn't
think about that your computers that's
what you do so we we're programmed by a
computer for most of the day it's only
when something unusual happens or the
chimp alerts us to a danger or
something's different that we move out
to Compu computer mode and then start
moving into chimpo human otherwise we
default back to computer mode which is
programmed by the chimpo human hence
that gives our
behaviors and is that is that the
autopilot that you refer to yeah the
autopilot is a constructive belief or
behavior so let's say simple example is
someone says socially I find it
difficult to get on with people and I
say let's have a look at how you
introduce yourself and let's say they're
com in and they're something very simple
is as an example uh and they say hello
and the person says hello and then
there's this pause and they say then I
feel really awkward and I just don't
know what to do yeah so what you've got
is you've actually got a program which
is to pause so that's a gremlin because
it's not helpful you're being
uncomfortable it's leading to an
emotional chimp reaction so we say right
what could we program the computer to do
so quite simple the social skills we
would just say ask them oh where have
you come from today and that breaks the
eye
so you're programming automatic speech
and then this art feels a lot better now
because I know what I'm doing and that's
no different to working with Elite
Sports people you know you program the
brain in sport to do certain reactions
certain positions certain behaviors uh
and then you repeat them and repeat them
if they're productive and helpful so if
you're working with an elite golfer the
swing is crucial to them so they'll
program themselves and the computer we
try and get them to just go into
computer mode because it's then
programmed whereas for them if they move
back to Chimp or human while they stood
waiting to tee off then they're going
back to trying to learn how to tee off
because the chimp and human don't have
those memory
banks so the computer has to take over
okay so it's like so it sounds like
programming the autopilot in a certain
way can help us manage goblins and
Gremlins that are other we remove them
we remove them uh to remove a gremlin
you must replace it with a new p pathway
you can't say I'm not going to do that
pathway so it's like people saying right
today I'm going to eat sensibly and then
they don't and you think well what did
you change in your beliefs or your
behaviors today because if you don't
change your belief or behavior and just
go in saying I'm going to eat then it's
likely you won't because you're going to
follow certain Pathways again and
certain beliefs like well if I have the
Mars bar now I'll I'll go to the gym and
run a bit longer on the treadmill which
it doesn't work yeah uh so you have to
change your belief and and alter it to
get a different Behavior coming out so
you have to bring in autopilots you have
to see and this again goes back to
people say well give me the autopilots
and that's I don't know what they are
because an autopilot for you might be
really strong and it works whereas for
me it won't resonate yeah so I have to
say what really resonates with you and
you gave me one if you said to me when I
released this book I believe if it helps
10 people I'm happy if you really
believe that that's going to be so
powerful to settle you down when a
criticism comes cuz you say we knew that
would come yeah happens to everybody
yeah you know um whereas if you don't
really believe it then it won't work and
you'll say you gave me that belief and
I'll say well okay and I need another
belief yeah you know and it could be
something which wouldn't work for me but
it might for you it might be as bizarre
as me saying what about recognizing as a
belief that if you don't get criticized
you're probably saying anything
powerful now that's a strange one but
someone would say you know what that
really resonates yeah the only person
who doesn't have enemies is a jellyfish
you know so once you've got a spine and
you've got a lifestyle or opinion or
your values you're going to get enemies
yeah and some people resonate with that
and say that makes sense that wouldn't
resonate with me but so I when I do a
call in the grade A hits these are the
autopilots that really make sense to you
and stabilize you so I have my own and I
like people to get about five grade A
hits where they say that really
resonates in life so a common one that
people use without my jargon would be
things like will this matter in a week's
time that for a lot of people is such a
powerful autopilot to think yeah you
know some people say well it will matter
you know if I'm in a relationship I
don't want to end and they leave me I'll
be scarred for life yeah and so they say
it does matter um and then I would
probably go down the rout of well will
you
cope or does this happen to everybody
and that might resonate and say yeah
life's going to throw us around a bit it
doesn't run smoothly so I what my job is
to find something that resonates and get
you to think and then when you say ah
that resonates to get you to keep using
it and how do you keep using it are we
talking like affirmations or like is
what's the you've got to start it's a
habit so for example the book I've
written a p of the Jungle is trying to
be very practical manual and I go
through this in detail and one of the
things I've done there which a lot of
people have got back to me so I'm glad
put it in was whenever something goes
wrong it's not what you want or it's not
what you expect the chimp kicks and you
get emotional reaction I say immediately
program yourself to say okay I've now
got an emotional message what's the plan
because that what's the plan from the
computer flicks you into human mode and
everybody says that's so powerful that's
good something happens I go okay what's
the plan and immediately I know because
you've shifted system there's a calmness
starts coming because the chimp's going
okay I don't have to worry now i' I've
alerted and you're on the ball now
you're coming up with a plan so it's
something as simple as that that you
have to learn every time I get emotional
stop and say okay what's the plan being
emotional isn't going to help so that's
the kind of stuff which it may not
resonate with everyone and I've tried to
put a lot in the book that people in the
past P when I Bo said that resonates
with me yeah you
know that's very good what's the plan
cuz I guess the chimp is the the warning
system but it's not the planning system
system exactly and people engage with
the emotion I keep saying that's not
what it's there for yeah so if you get
anxious go thank you thank the chimp
you've got me anxious let me work the
plan out let's get a solution let's see
what it is and sometimes the plan may
not solve the solution so let's I'll go
back to relationships cuz it's big one
in most people's lives and let's say
that the relationship's going wrong and
it's something you don't want to go
wrong and you get very emotional as this
person says look I'm sorry but I think
this is the end of the line um and your
emotions go and you say what's the plan
and you think well there isn't a plan
because it is the end of the line well
there is a plan the plan is to say for
example it may not resonate with
everyone this happens to lots of people
we do get over it yes we could even be
emotionally scarred but Life Will Go On
nearly everybody finds somebody else if
that's what you want yeah and life life
will continue if you have that in your
head and say it will take around 3
months on average you'll go through a
lot of emotions but you will come out
the other side so take a deep breath
you've got three months of a rot and
Tumble coming for someone to have that
as the plan Y is a good plan because
you're saying I'm accepting it's got to
I've got to go through
it so taking a much more dramatic
example which and everyone's different
in what how they approach it my Approach
uh as said Psychiatry is not happy world
so I deal with unfortunately from time
to time parents who've lost a child they
died in their sleep or an accident and
this is tragic I cannot change that and
they can't change we all know that uh
and then to say what's the plan would be
a little bit unkind y instead you got to
work through but I'd explain we we're
going to go through grief not everyone
would agree with me I say to them you
won't recover I don't think you recover
and you won't even come to terms with it
what you'll do is you'll manage the
system but you'll have some good days in
the future and you'll have some terrible
days we're going to learn how to manage
them and things will will get better but
you will be scarred and I found that's
really helpful to people because it's
reality yeah so there you've got what's
the plan but it's done in a much gent
way because obviously you can imagine
emotional distress is just incredibly
painful and then it doesn't set up like
a false expectation or a hope in their
mind of like they're going to be
completely back to normal yeah and so
just saying that that's never going to
happen but let's figure out a way to
manage this yeah until to the less of
though obviously really painful EXT a
broken relationship yeah that can be a
loss of a job it can be where you didn't
want to leave a job but there's a bully
in the company or you just can't
tolerate it anymore and you've go
through a grief reaction you think this
your identity might go uh there's a lot
of areas where I'd give a lot of TLC but
also you know a little bit of like come
on we still need a plan but that plan
can be that how do I deal with the
feeling things of loss how do I deal
with the really bad emotions I'm
experiencing it doesn't mean let's be
positive I'm not a keen fan of that if
I'm honest I'm Keen fan of let's let's
use reality and reality can be positive
but I'm also reality is sometimes you
can't be positive there is a negative
yeah there's nothing good about
something which you know is a
Devastation to you I don't think that's
helpful to say that yeah I think the
answer is sometimes we get scared
oh by the way in case you have not yet
heard my book is about to come out it's
called Feelgood productivity how to do
more what matters to you and it's a book
that I've been working on for the last 3
years now it's being published at the
end of December 2023 but pre-orders are
actually available and I know people
don't like pre-ordering the book but if
you do pre-order the book and you email
me your receipt you will get completely
free access to a live exclusive event
that I'm hosting in the first weekend of
January of 2024 and this is a live
online Workshop all about annual
planning goal setting and reflection and
so I'm going to be facilitating a group
with hopefully hundreds of people from
all around the world and we're going to
be going through how to figure out what
to do with our life and how to turn that
into goals for the year and how to build
systems and how to be consistent with
stuff and how to make sure that we are
enjoying the journey along the way that
is purely exclusively available for
people who pre-order the book as a thank
you for our little community so if you
want to check it out you can check out
the book you can maybe consider
pre-ordering it the link will be down in
the video description we mentioned how
um the chimp is the sort of warning
system makes us feel anxious or
disturbed I wonder what's your view on
how how granular should we go in trying
to understand the emotions in the sense
of is I feel Disturbed enough or is it
important to go deeper to be like okay
I'm think I think I'm feeling
frustration or irritation which is a
subset of anger okay like I'm really
okay nailing the the specific emotion
versus just I'm feeling a bit like off
about the situation I think it depends
on the person again um because some
people don't want to go heavy they just
keep it simple and really simple um
where someone says to me I'd like to
understand more then we go to the depth
they won't understand but there is a
point you have to say don't overanalyze
because you can you know it's death by
analysis and at the end of the day you
got to have some element of spontaneity
but I think that's up to the person uh
what I do say is like you give some
words there frustration anger you know
and I say well let's look at the most
appropriate word and and often the
chimp's vocabulary is quite Limited in a
lot of people so they end up calling
themselves an an angry person because
what they say is if something goes wrong
I get angry and they don't have an
alternative word so I work with people
say what do you want to use as an
alternative could despondent be a better
word so they start learning to train
their chimp to use different vocabulary
and clearly the way the brain works if I
say I'm angry then it alerts systems to
be angry I'm telling my brain this is
what you need to be uh so I actually
start behaving it whereas if I say I'm
despondent it's changed my mindset
instantly so I like to do vocabulary
training for the chimp oh nice yeah I do
and then I I've done some fun sessions
of people saying give me uh you know 20
different words describing what you say
is anger but isn't because there's a big
difference between anger and frustration
there a big difference between anger and
disappointment or being let down yeah
you know or whatever it would be uh so
we have a lot of words and then we try
and use the vocabulary to say right
what's the word I'm really experiencing
and that's almost like programing an
autopilot that when I experience
something don't call it anger your
computer goes what's another word and if
you start using them you think I've got
other words so you can see what I tend
to do with people is emotional skills
training where you you're really using
your intelligence your brain to say how
can I manage this machine to get the
best out of
me there's an app that I that a a
previous podcast guest actually
recommended to me it's uh it's very
interesting it's in fact I'll I'll do a
screen recording so we'll we'll show
this on screen for anyone who is
watching this on YouTube um it's a free
app it's called how we feel which is is
is interesting so you click on the app
you do like a a check-in and then so
have a look so it gives you these four
options okay how am I feeling so it's
like high energy pleasant high energy
unpleasant low energy Pleasant and if
you click on one of them yeah you'll see
what it
does and it gives you the all of this
vocabulary of like ah okay so I've been
finding this really helpful it gives me
an Apple Watch notification a couple of
times a day how are we feeling I click
on it and be like oh okay I'm feeling
relief and serenity and tranquility and
as all these words were before if
someone asked me how do I feel i' been
like yeah fine yeah but now this almost
like it's a nice easy way to train the
Train the vocabulary to be a bit more
yeah and that's why I'd say to people
then you start realizing there is such a
choice but it's not just that I'm
thinking let's just use a word uh once
we pick a word in the brain the brain
reacts to that word and it's banked on
lots of things so it once you use the
word anger the system is set up to
immediately kick in and it often becomes
either defensive and aggressive or it
becomes withdrawing and panicky um
whereas if you choose other
words uh which are less emotive then you
will experience a less emotional
reaction so it's learning to saying oh
this is a machine I can actually
manipulate this um so I do this as in
detail I've tried I know a lot of people
so I'm going to push it now yeah uh the
reason I wrote a path of the Jungle over
the years it took me 10 years to follow
chimp Paradox uh is people kept saying
chimp Paradox is great it introduced you
to a model and it's like you know for
those who resonate it's it completely
changes the way you see yourself uh but
a path through the jungle what they kept
saying is it doesn't help us to really
do the skills it's not really mind
management so I wanted to do a course
which I've done in there so it works
from Dot and goes through 27 units
saying like things like this that might
resonate with someone and say that's
really helpful whereas others can skip
the exercise the what's the plan might
with the one they say that's changed me
but there's lots of others and I think
I've tried to do as many as I can so
anyone picking up and say four or five
of these really resonate or 50 resonate
but it is a CA cuz I think that's what
people kept saying to me is it's all
well and good talking all this but how
do I start and do it structured Y and
work over time on this um so I was
saying to one of you staff's a big book
I originally was going to call it one
year uh because I wanted the people to
realize the 27 units and I was saying do
one every couple of weeks let it absorb
let it practice it so you're building
like learning a language y rather than
read it and you think it's all very good
and you forget I I want it to be working
practice so nice that's what it was
written for so if people do say where's
the followup that's it I haven't got
another one that yeah um yeah just to
the point of the the that I really like
that thing around you know the the
emotion that we label is actually
informs our our response yeah um I've
been working with a therapist recently
and one thing that he said which I found
really helpful that really resonated was
underneath every anger is a hurt yeah
and in a relationship expressing anger
is generally unproductive but expressing
sadness hurt generally is an opportunity
to connect and so in in my relationship
for example whenever I feel anything
resembling frustration irritation anger
I think what's what's the hurt
underneath this and try my best to
express the hurt rather than the anger
and it's just been gamechanging in the
last in the last few months I mean this
is so well than likeing grief reactions
anger is much easier uh to do than grief
so we know this is a common experience
when people make a loss of anything um
or someone CL course there's an anger
that comes with it often named it
doctors or nursing staff um and we
understand that that people can't deal
with a grief it's too painful anger is
not as painful but it's interesting I'm
an animal lover and I say this about
dogs that dogs are not normally angry
they're they're worried so a dog that's
aggressive is generally a very nervous
worried dog yeah um there is subtlety
sometimes anger or is bordering from
frustration where PE people have an
expectation of what should happen I try
and remove the word should it's a chimp
word for me uh a human word is could so
I often say replace should by could and
it changes it so you know I should get
an Olympic medal can lead to frustration
anger where I could get an Olympic medal
gives an opportunity but it may not
happen so I'm I'm keen on words I think
they do make a big difference but anger
yeah often comes from
expectation the should yeah speaking of
words uh one one distinction that you
make is the difference between control
and manage Mass I wonder if you can
expand on that yeah again I mean again
I'd be happy to criticize on the fact
that it's semantics but I think
semantics are really important yeah I
think so but I think if someone says for
example look come on control your
emotions the implication is the word
control means you can if you want to
whereas that's some kind because you
can't manage your emotions is different
manage means you hope you can do it but
management is a skill control is an
option oh nice and that's why I see the
difference so I think when I hear people
saying control your emotions I think
that's quite abusive almost to the
person because you're asking them to do
something they can't do it's like saying
jump out the window and fly you wouldn't
do that and yet say control your
emotions we can't otherwise we would you
know nobody wants to lose it emotionally
so but manage means you've got an option
here and it's a skill so that's why I'm
really pushy to say nobody controls
their mind we manage it and some days we
don't do it well it's a skill so and I
get this a lot have I got a chimp and I
say I've got a gorilla you know uh and I
have a chimp and does it get out
absolutely can I manage it usually
usually cuz my chimp sort of knows the
rules so I work with it but does that
mean it doesn't ever get out no it gets
out and I don't want my chimp to be in a
box again sometimes it's good for it to
come out I may have to stop it and say
stop stop but I don't want people to be
I don't want to be a robot I don't want
to be this person who shows no emotion
you know but on the other hand I have to
recognize when it's damaging so if my
chimp has a rant then that could be
really helpful for my chimp to just have
a rant as long as the people around me
know I'm in chimp M and I'm ranting and
they all ignore me then I'm happy and
I'll say okay I'll finish ranting and I
say now as a human so I'm not saying we
should be in human mode I'm not saying
that people keep saying this and they
also keep saying human is logic chimp is
emotion that's not true either both use
emotion both use logic I've always said
this it's just the human starts with
logic and bases their emotion on the
logic so I still experience a lot of
emotion as a human yeah my chimp uses
emotion and bases Logic on it which is
not a sound yeah so I'm saying just
recognize the difference and switch so I
you know I think if you were without
emotion it must be awful yeah so I don't
want to be non-emotional and I don't
want to be in human mode all the time
there's times I think being in chimp
Mode's good as long as I can manage it
to say stop stop you're going over the
top and pull a chimp in and say right
you've had enough now yeah we we we've
talked a lot about uh negative emotions
as it relates to the chimp because that
tends to be the thing that holds people
back um how do you think of positive
emotions and how that relates to Chimp
plus human loads and loads of positives
um interestingly if you look at the
Neuroscience it's the chimp that makes
us laugh there are no laughter circuits
in humans yeah because the reason is
that the human is slow it's a slow
system so we're second to work the chimp
that's why we're impulsive often in
speech and actions and the human comes
in second thinking hang on I should have
thought about that right but if we're
listening to how the chimp operates it
believes what it hears immediately and
then it challenges it or hands to the
human you say what do you think so
that's why we often were gullible yeah
and then you mentioned being on holiday
and a guy saying please help me and your
chimp's going I believe he's struggling
and he's a genuine guy that's gullible
right and your human should have stepped
in and said hang on yeah there's a
reason this is happening um so your
chimp was gullible and this is the basis
of laughter you know when we hear a joke
and the punch line the chimp believes
the joke and then suddenly the punch
line comes and it laughs yeah so it's
actually three different circuits within
the chimp all operating so it has to
accept the reality then the
contradiction and then merth is a third
circuit so it makes us laugh so the
chimp gives us laughter you know and the
human's pretty slow to take it up on
that yeah uh so that's one example the
chin gives us motivation I'm not a fan
of motivation because I get a lot of
talks please motivate our company or
motivate and I said I don't want to do
that uh the alternative uh option is I
mention ear his commitment so I'll give
a simple example let's say I'm not a
gardener So and I've got to weed the
garden the neighbors are complaining and
it is a mess and I'm saying I just can't
get out there I can't get out there and
my chimp won't let me go cuz it's saying
it's too big it's overwhelmed so I'm now
procrastinating uh the chimp might one
day get up and say when I'm in the right
mood when I'm motivated I'm going to
well that's ridiculous uh in my opinion
so I'd say to my chimp right you tell
you what I don't care what I feel I'm
going out you stay where you are I'm
going to do a commitment it needs to be
done I'm not interested in being the
right mood what tends to happen is once
I do that commitment my chimp gets
motivated yeah so it's just stepping
back and saying switch system say let's
do commitment and get on with what I
need to do yeah not interest that is
definitely one measure that we show
success in people I'm not saying they
can't do it by motivation but it's
harder to do so I like to say the chimp
is about motivation and excitement the
humans about commitment and inspiration
but then they work together cuz my chimp
when I've weeded a third of the garden
will get annoyed and say why have you
waited this long to do this and start
chewing me up when I'm thinking well it
wasn't me that waited uh so therefore
I've learned to switch systems on things
I don't my chimp doesn't want to do but
I've got to do
them at the risk of being pedantic about
semantics um how do you feel about the
word discipline and willpower and how
does that relate to this I'll get into
trouble here um will power would suggest
there are circuits where you can tell
the chimp what you're going to do and
you have strength to do that and there
aren't any circuits neuroscientifically
you can't control the orbit of frontal
in the imig you can influence them so
technically we got modulating but
actually they'll have the last say and
that's crucial to do because if a crisis
situation happen where my life is in
danger then I don't want to start
thinking logically what do I do I need
to act
impulsively uh with the defense
mechanism so there's a reason Nature has
made us so we're impulsive uh but it's
not really applicable nowadays because
we're not living in a a jungle area or
in danger we've put ourselves in a
society where we're
generally not at risk uh but there will
be moments there will be so willpower
would suggest that now I'll get into
trouble and so I avoid it by saying
there aren't circuits of control but
there are circuits of management so
we're back to saying the reason I picked
this model is to take that pressure off
people because my experience has been
you're going back down to control and
then I get a lot of people who start
beating themsel up saying what is wrong
with me and I keep saying you're seeing
it wrongly in my opinion what you're
saying is how do I get the management
skills I need to up skill Y and it is a
skill so some people will do it really
well and some people will struggle but
we can all improve so I encourage people
everyone can improve in emotional
management okay but some people are
better than others but that's true of
any skill but that's why I go away from
willpower yeah and discipline I think a
better word is to say how do I switch
systems and work with my emotions and
learn to manage them so that we do what
I want rather than what my chimp might
be doing you mentioned that human is
inspiration what's the I mean
inspiration and motivation seem somewhat
similar how what's your distinction
between the two okay um again it could
argue semantics motivation is a feeling
I'm in the right mood I want to do this
I'm excited um which may or may not
result in something uh inspiration is a
feeling that I can do this uh it's going
to be well-being or it's going to help
people it's going to help me so you're
inspired to do it so it's a driving
force that gives you a
vision that's I think I think it's
subtle yeah and I think if you think it
through they're both emotional like I
said uh the human works with emotion but
it's basing on logic and the inspiration
is I've got a vision here I can see what
whereas motivation can often just be I'm
in the right place now and look at the
gains look at the rewards so it's a
different one the chimp's looking at um
and there's nothing wrong with this
achievement success ESS possession
whereas the humans more likely to use
things like fulfillment of values yep um
a good feel good Factor yeah like the
service component like in service to
others yeah and it's longterm or is The
Chimps much more usually um in the
immediate Here and Now doesn't think a
consequence thinks of just what's
happening at the moment yeah no
long-term Vision one thing that so we
we've got like a a telegram Community
around the podcast and we always ask
questions to be like hey what would you
like us to to talk about one topic that
always comes about is anxiety um I think
especially increasingly it seems young
people experiencing a lot of anxiety the
whole social media comparison that we we
all get into how do you I mean it's a
big question but how do you think about
anxiety as it relates to the chimp model
anxiety is a message from the chimp to
say all is not well and your job I say
is to as as a human is to say right what
is it that's causing the anxiety so if
you look at where anxiety comes from
neuroscientifically y uh it isn't the
amydala people no it's not no no it's
not the amydala uh the amydala works
with figure yeah and it's working with
fight flight frees okay so if you look
close by there is another nucleus which
it's probably because it got a bigger
name uh so the bed nucleus of the stri
terminalis works with Fe with with
anxiety so this is the area that looks
at uh and and it's interesting that in
an emergency situation it doesn't appear
it doesn't work for about 10 minutes The
amigdala Works to give you fight flight
freeze after about 10 minutes give or
take it seems to wake up now it brings
beliefs in now anxiety can be created so
anxiety is based usually around beliefs
y it can be based around trigger points
and behaviors yep so for example if you
see a snake appear in the room for a lot
of people that would create and anxiety
but if you think the reason it's a
trigger point and it's almost inbuilt um
I think children need to read that
because we told that it's inbuilt from
birth but my experience is having got
rescue animals children are more keen on
touching the snake than they are the
rabbit so that so but the snake would
create anxiety because your belief is
it's dangerous y as if we said that it
doesn't have fangs for example it's been
defanged for whatever reason uh and it's
not venomous then you might change your
mind so your beliefs are usually behind
anxiety and it's often a belief I can't
cope yeah now again I don't know this is
so unique to the person of what's
creating the anxiety but let's say it's
a change of a job and the anxie is there
about will I make the bills uh can I do
the new job and there's a lot of emotion
going on and and anxiety mixes in with
it what it's really saying is can you
cope have have you got a plan again and
is the plan good enough yeah is it
rigorous and can you guarantee it
because the chimp ridiculously wants
guarantees and we know that nearly
everything in life there's no guarantees
so we have to say to the chimp there are
no guarantees you got to live with that
yep and that's hard for the chimp to do
but what we can reassure with is
although there are no guarantees I'm
always going to be active to find
Solutions and if I can't I know people
who can yeah now for a lot of people
that can reassure them you're not alone
yeah so one of the big things working
with people is to remind them I'm
whatever battle they're going through
I'm going through it with them I have no
intention of leaving the battle uh and
so I would say to right I'm going to
take you through it and that for a lot
of chimps will relax them so anxiety is
very unpleasant and it's use your on
beliefs it can be learned behaviors it
needs analyzing but the answer is always
going to be the same is what address the
problem don't live that come up with a
solution come up with a plan and the
plan might be we don't know so let's
take a deep breath and wait till we
see nice yeah that's good
um things like ADHD does that work with
the with with the model yep so again
ADHD is a medical condition um again
there's always debates about is it well
diagnosed uh so I'm not going to go
there say let's assume we've got some
with ADHD the easiest way I try to
explain this is if you imagine the brain
is an orchestra yep and the conductor is
asleep then it's really noisy um so we
need to wake the conductor up because
people always say why would you give
someone ADHD amphetamines which are
alerting drugs when they're already
hyperactive and what you're doing is
waking up the conductor in the brain so
the parts of the brain that are not
active become active and then they tap
the button and the orchestra settles
down as an executive
function exactly so and that can be
lifechanging for people with ADHD um
obviously we I don't dive in I'm sure
most doctors wouldn't we try and do it
behaviorally because you can with
children or adults but it would be
unkind if somebody's brain isn't
functioning in the way they want it to
uh to leave them with that so you do
medicate then so it's not taken on
lightly but sometimes medication can
bring person to life and they'll say
it's just a God send because now I can
function I can form relationships I can
study I can do a job you know I can soci
social settings so all this I've heard
having done these but my first part tool
would be to try and train the mind into
the computer system learning how to
behave so the computer starts taking
over which is what we do with children
not dive into drugs yeah but they still
work with the chimp model they still
work with it I worked with a very young
lad um who was susp suspected of having
ADHD he didn't have it uh and I decided
we'd do this and he actually pulled his
parents in line with the chimp model he
did warn them when they were in chimp
mod so I always say to parents if you're
going to use this model with your kids
get ready yeah because they'll
definitely definitely pull on
it and then um something like depression
how does that fit into the chip model
okay when I again tried to simplify
things so we didn't get too technical I
used to call it and still do malfunction
is where the brain isn't working and
dysfunction is where it's working but
you're not running it well okay so it's
a b like a car you know if it's broken
down you need a mechanic if it's not
broken down you need to learn how to
drive y all right um so malfunction
depression is an umbrella term we know
that some people when it's mild to
moderate you can do talking therapies uh
and they'll improve so things like C
behavioral therapy which is used for
many conditions is very powerful and
people resonate with that it's fantastic
um therapists do a great job with that
but we know that that if it goes severe
with a lot what we call biological
symptoms then it doesn't appear to
respond to talking therapies so now
we're down the route to saying right we
need some form of
medication um and that's where you we're
now into deeper water the problem is
often um a lot of GPS are under a lot of
pressure so when people come in they're
getting such short times to assess them
as psychiatrist we give them the luxury
of an hour uh they don't get that so
it's advisable for them to sit trying
anti-depressant
which if the person's got a biological
illness then they're probably going to
respond but not everyone does and there
are dangers with it yeah so you have to
warn people uh but the the vast majority
won't suffer side effects the vast
majority don't have these but that
doesn't help the people who do so again
it's this risk benefit yeah and the
doctor has to make that decision and
it's never easy the ideal is to avoid
the medication but if you need it don't
hesitate yeah cuz it would be cruel if
somebody's not well it's like holding
back thyroxin from someone who's got a
thyroid problem and you're saying that
you know you can't say to them like come
on let's get some energy yeah you got to
treat
it but that's a really it's a really
difficult area actually so like my mom's
a psychiatrist for example but she's not
been called on to consult with the
England football team how did how did
the cool stuff happen where where you
ended up working with like Ron solivan
and like Steven Gerard and like these
Elite performers by accident uh again I
mean had a very interesting life and
people say to me oh you've done so many
things it's never been planned I I'm a
leaf in the wind I see where the wind
takes me um with a little bit of
direction but I was working at shepel
medical school at the time when one of
my previous students took a job uh with
the cycling team and said look got a guy
who's got mental health problems can you
do me a favor and see him and so I went
along saw this guy and um I can only
name people that have you know gone
public uh and worked with him he did
exceptionally well and so the head of
cycling said what did you do and quite
frankly I didn't know I was I'm a doctor
and I said I'm just trying to get it to
explain how his mind works um and he
gave me uh Chris Hoy and said we'd like
to meet this young man uh and Chris is
it was a dream to work with I'm still in
touch with Chris a lovely guy absolute
gentleman um got very nice chimp as well
uh which is really well behaved but
Chris knew what he wanted from me and
that set it off and and we worked really
well as a team um and he worked hard and
he was already in a good place it wasn't
about emotions Chris it was about
performance yeah and focus and so on and
then he said I want you to come to
Athens Olympics so I went undercover um
and got off of the job with them and
refused it because I said you know I'm a
doctor and I've trained to help people
but there was a moment I thought you
know I said I'm not a sports fan but
most of Brit are and uh and I realized
actually helping people people wherever
they are was what I want to do and if I
can help Sports people in whatever areas
they want performance or their life or
lifestyle whatever then maybe I'm
helping the public too so it took me a
year to jump so I was at rampton doing
fic psych and uh I jumped and started
working Elite Sport and it just exploded
and I got off of jobs everywhere yeah
and then obviously I like to learn the
sports and uh being great to get support
from um other people in the sports who
would guide me on the you know each
sport as I came to it so I worked very
close with coaches as well as athletes
because I have to learn each environment
so working with Ronnie uh obviously he's
a friend and I've worked with him over
10 years and he's a great guy um have to
learn the rules of snooker which again
is weird where you have to silence
during play as opposed to England
football where it's deafening uh but
have to learn football and then have to
learn individuals so it was exciting
chall all and every Sport's different so
that was accidental um and then I just
got stuck with Sport and and people
started wrongly calling me a sport
psychiatrist and that's not true and I'd
say quarter of my work if that maybe 20%
is Sport 80% is working with doctors
still working with um students working
with the public yeah teachers a lot with
education yeah uh the police so I do
very generic work nice and so like
writing the books and forming the
business around it like how does that
fit into your clinical well stuff when I
was helping people obviously and one
person and the demands were getting
enormous and you realize just how tough
it is out there for people as human
beings I realize wow it's bigger than I
thought because as a doctor you in
hospital you get your outpatient clinics
and I'm seeing severe curses uh where
suddenly your public came to light and
it was like this Mass really bad place
for the public you know anxiety States
you say stress relationship problems um
Lots organizational problems uh so I
formed a company and I said as long as
it's helping people are not making lots
of money uh I'll I'll do it so I've got
a brilliant team of 12 mentors and we've
been together a long time now um and
support staff yeah um so it's a small
team really and we do work across the
board uh to try and help people who
resonate with the chimp model so that it
didn't it wasn't planned it's happened
uh and it's working well uh for those
who
resonate nice so I mean your career is
is very sort of I mean like it's like
reading about it I'm just like whoa all
of it just seems really really cool you
know why cuz I'm old really yeah I
people say how have we doing this much
because I'm old I've been around and you
know it like I said the the sport just
that was an opportunity that just
appeared and I just helped out and then
it started to take off and then from the
sport you can imagine I got into
television and I did some Tele shows and
then workshops and and then radio and
podcasts and and suddenly it was media
and then from there it was like suddenly
I got um actors uh musicians and you
think oh wow you know and I'm learning
then what's it like being on stage and
what the peculiarities of doing the West
End or or a television soap I've got to
learn every time and I need to know the
environment of this person so you can
see it wasn't
planned um and even the forensic wasn't
planned I was General adult um and it
was just working I became Clinical
Director of a hospital and so uh you
tended to get the cases people didn't
want and I had to do that so I took on
some of the forensics in the community
at the time and Alcohol Services and
from there the police got involved
saying look you're working with two guys
who giv death threats on you and yeah
and I said okay uh and I did say what's
the plan and they said there isn't one
which I thought okay just letting you
know and I didn't Flinch so the head of
rampton was at that meeting and said you
really need to work with the rampton
patience because you're not phased by it
and that so was a change of career and
then went to forensics and really
learned a lot and again that's where I
started really looking at the human mind
and
predictability uh and obviously helping
students um a lot of them 18 to 23 is
most of them uh were going through a lot
of traumas just finding them themselves
in life so these were big challenges for
me to try and apply the Neuroscience so
I've got to thank all these people yeah
so but yeah it's been great it's great
when when we were in medical school like
there was a real sense of pressure that
everyone needs to have figured out their
life plan cuz they would be like the
handful of kids in the year who'd be
already gunning for their st3
applications in neurosurgery and already
doing all the stuff and Publishing 10
papers and the rest of us are like uh
can barely get one like letter to edit
or publish and it doesn't even have a
pub ID so it doesn't count it's like
there's a lot of the Mind potentially
try thinking that it has to have a very
clear like life plan I think especially
amongst Medics who are used to having a
you know long-term career trajectory
what advice would you give to people who
are maybe like a finally a medical
student thinking like they need to have
everything everything sorted okay I mean
there is pressure and I think the
trouble is let's say that I don't just
make a figure up 10% of students know
exactly what they want to do they want
to be you know cardiac surgeon and
that's so they're going to do a PhD and
whatever don't compare yourself to them
I was in the 10% that thought at the
time I thought GP so I did do GP
training but um then I realiz it
probably wasn't for me um so I think the
answer is I would suggest this step back
don't compare and just say why have I
come into this profession and what
pathway do I want to follow because you
know getting through the exams you just
work hard and you get through and then
you find your feet it's become a little
more difficult now because uh I a
dinosaur and we could form our own
rotations we could jump around so I
could do six months Pediatrics six
months OBS and guing you can't do that
now it's not possible you have to go
down a certain route and and I think
that's probably not a good thing with
doctors if I'm honest um because I think
my feeling was I did like I said GP
taught me a lot you know which I
wouldn't have got in psyche I don't
think um and I think jumping around you
get a lot more of a basis of general
medicine which in which goes across
anything when you're treating people
holistically so I think at the end of
the day where our doctors are not super
Specialists but I also accept there will
be doctors who want to be super
Specialists who just say all I want to
do is this discipline and have an
awareness of the rest so I'd certain to
medical students um first of all step
back and get a bigger picture life is
going to go on whever you do and you'll
get through whatever you do and like for
my example I know I'm extreme you have
no idea what opportunities are coming
and when you get out there suddenly
opportunities will unfold and the NHS is
Shifting ground and hopefully we can get
it together properly uh and it'll be
more doctor friendly I don't think it is
at the moment um but it's probably not
friendly for everybody uh so if we get
that it's going to change the landscape
again so just live in the moment and
just do what you do and what's your like
when it comes to like let's say you're
going through a career and you've got
like opportunity A or B or C and it's
like each each will take you down a
different path that's sort of hard to
imagine what sort of Frameworks or
systems do you use for making decisions
in that context of which path you you
want to go down it's almost difficult
because um if you inspire people say I
get medical I Inspire them and they say
I want to be a psychiatrist you you've
inspired them and maybe anyone could I
could have been an you know obstetrician
and they said oh I want to obstetrician
if I'm inspiring them so we often go on
our teachers and doctors we meet and I
which is you know at the end of the day
most of us any human being not just
doctors can choose a career and just
make the most of it you know so I don't
think it would have mattered maybe I'm
wrong if I had stayed in surgery or if I
had gone into GP I think it's just
finding an environment and and a
discipline that I feel fulfilled in so
helping people could have been done in
many ways and psyche was not my first
choice definitely not it was only that
when I got in in GP that I thought wow
these people are so vulnerable and I
didn't feel they were getting a good
deal when I was training as a student I
felt it wasn't taught well um I think
it's moved ground a lot now um but I was
determined to lift that standard so I
think with uh medical students I don't
think they'll get too uptight I think
you just make it Choice um and there are
ways of changing I do know doctors have
changed career as in like they've
changed come out of medicine or as
you've done uh or they've uh changed
within medicine it is possible to change
and maybe we get more flexible of that
um for medical students listening there
was a big move I don't know what's
happened to it now where they were
saying to people like me uh say this 20
years ago so I would be now a consultant
for some time and to stop us being stale
they would say why don't you move to an
Allied discipline and we do a 12mth
upgrade so I could have gone for example
close Allied Fields might be U neurology
or Endocrinology so I would retrain for
12 months under endocrinology and then
move disciplines and that might doctors
in the profession so those who feel I
want a bit more of a challenge yeah I'm
not sure what happened to that so
there's possibilities that we might
start to look up but we're going off
piece to good sorry um one thing I'm
curious about so you've um I guess
coached spoken to a lot of people who by
external metrics are rich and famous and
successful and have won the medals and
all that stuff to what extent is there a
relationship between those external
markers of success and like happiness
fulfillment that yeah those those things
there common sense that if you sat there
with someone who was a multi-billionaire
or you know the chance of them being
happy is a bit higher than someone who's
really worrying where the next meal's
coming from it's blatantly obvious so
when people say money doesn't make you
happy that's true but blind me it goes a
long way so so you know the real world
is we have to make money to just survive
and then it does give us the extra
things um however however
yeah I mean I've worked with the whole
Spectrum so I worked with people who are
you know at one point I worked with down
anounce years back uh and who were
struggling and just on the street and
you know I'll work with anyone who comes
to the door and say let's work within
what your life's offering in what you
can do you know uh but do I get people
who are really rich uh and unhappy
absolutely you know uh because again the
chimp may be happy with what they've got
but the humans looking for something
something much more meaningful so if
they're all chimp then that person's
probably going to always be happy some
people stay in chimp mode if they're
someone who's much more human than they
are chimp then this achievement can
disillusion them yeah you know and then
they'll be they come to me and say I
just feel unfulfilled I just feel life's
empty and it often is the case they're
in chimp mode and trying to get into
human and there's nothing there and we
have to look at then what their values
are what are they doing it for a bit
like we said a minute ago with the
medical students you got to ask why did
you come into medicine you know and if
it was to help people then why are you
worrying about whether you got on a
rotation or you'll get to help people
yeah you know so step back and get the
bigger picture so the answer to your
question about the richness of course it
helps because people don't have to worry
about certain things uh but I still get
rich businessmen who come in worrying
and worrying and they're doing so well
in terms of their method of success yep
but then they'll talk about I don't
relate to my daughter and they'll say
how do I get her to love me I can't
communicate how and you think this is so
sad and then you see you know money
doesn't buy that so sometimes people do
come in and it's not what you think but
I get why people are struggling with
money might look and be resentful and
think well it's easy for them to come in
and say that because you know sure they
have no money
problems tough one when one thing I've
read about recently is they called it
they called it gold medal syndrome which
is once you've once you've won the gold
medal at that point you're like G well
I've kind of won the game now what is
what more is there to do um I guess you
know people like you know the people
that you've worked with yeah have won
the gold medal yeah what do they do next
like how do they how do they find
fulfillment once youve already hit the
Pinnacle it's a common problem and you
you get this in management as well and
they get it in doctors I've got doctors
who say I've now become a consultant and
now what what yeah is this it y um and
again I've got to start saying well we
have to accept that if you want to
challenge let's look at what you want
for the challenge it may not be
achievement per se it may be doing
something which is fulfilling which is a
sort of achievement yeah so you know
even learning a new musical instrument
joining a choir uh going in a rambling
group it start to look at life
differently and saying this could be a
success instead of always having that
challenge you know saying I got to
achieve but if you get someone who says
no I want another achievement I think
sometimes you have to go into this
reality land that if you've got an
Olympic gold medal you're not going to
probably achieve in another sport you
might one or two people would have but
you're probably not so you'll change
over and you won't do as well but see is
a challenge see how far can I get in
that Sport and also if you've uh as H
Sports people they've aged so you're
physically not as strong so you've got
to look and say do you want to get out
of sport or do you want to stay it but
do a different sport but accept age made
play a part of it yeah it's getting them
to re accept that you may have reached a
pinnacle y that there won't ever be
another moment like the Olympic gold
medal yeah you know that's reality but
it's looking to see could there be some
golden moments which are
different you know uh because again it's
for me I'm someone who um I'm not that
much into the achievement it's nice to
achieve but for me um I live on a farm
and I do animal rescue so patting the
donkey is is more rewarding than another
decree you think I not another degree
yeah you know uh which sounds ridiculous
but but it's true that the thing so I
reset my one of my values what's going
to make me feel really good and rescuing
the animal would probably do that
rescuing a person is great how do you
figure out what your values are that's
really difficult because whenever I say
this to people because I I pushed this
point I trying to keep things very black
and white just to make it accessible
that if we look at peace of mind that's
the only thing that gives people peace
of mind not happiness peace of mind so
your rest is your values and living them
out so defining your values is never
easy and there's so many different ways
people say what is a value so I go
through this a bit uh when I'm working
with people is I say to them a value is
a moral stance that you're taking it's
what the right thing is in your eyes
it's doing the right thing but it's an
action attached to it so for example and
people say one of my values is
respecting other people and if I respect
them I feel good if I disrespect
somebody I feel bad so there's your
piece of Mind lost yeah right and you
can gain it back apologies never go
wrong um so I say to them well how do
you demonstrate respect and what they
don't know is how to demonstrate it so I
try and help them to clarify it and see
let's give you some ideas so one of the
ones is is is listening to someone
doesn't mean you have to agree with them
but it does mean you have to understand
them so you give them space you don't
have to agree but you have to make sure
they they get that you understand and
respect that opinion now that if they
say yeah that would be respect they
learn to do it so I ask people when I'm
working them to actually count how many
times in the week say I see them in a
week's time how many times you
demonstrate Respect by stopping that no
stop I need to listen to you first but I
need to listen and I need to check I've
understood
right then I'll discuss it that's an
example of a value in action so for me I
like values in action because at the end
of the day whatever life's throwing at
you I ask people look in the mirror and
say did I live by my values today am I
proud of the person that sat in front of
me because that can override once you
start doing that things like uh did I do
well in an exam or what do people think
of me it can override all of that
and to what extent do you
find like there are some values that are
I guess more selfish values and some
that are more like service oriented yeah
like for me I find like when whenever I
do a values funding exercise or anything
like freedom and autonomy often come
fairly high on the
list and that's a very selfish value so
I want the freedom to do whatever I want
and like to be able to not do things I
don't want to do and stuff and it's you
know I've I know I know a few people who
are older than me who who were like yeah
when I was in my 20s I also had freedom
as a value and then I got a family and I
realized there were more important
things how do you what do you see is is
the balance between kind of I guess yeah
these self-oriented values versus other
oriented values on the individual you
you hit a number of points there one is
that we have a hierarchy of
values um and you have to work out what
your hierarchy is but that can shift and
your values can shift you know and
because they may shift on your
beliefs you know so if your value is I
will always help someone who asks for
help that is a value I hold so when you
went to holl do you want to help that
guy even though they saying you're being
sucked in whereas you might rethink your
belief that actually it's not a value to
help someone who's using you so you've
modified how you see that value it
doesn't mean you're not going to help
someone but what you've now said
whenever I know someone is genuine I
will always help them that's a modified
value yeah so we have to revise our
values put them into a hierarchy of
which are the important ones here yep so
you might have respect for others and
self-respect and you've got to decide I
can't give you the answer you can what's
the difference and how do I make sure
I've done it the right way around and
then you don't lose your peace of mind
but if you put your hierarchy the wrong
way around then again your peace of mind
will probably go even though you're
living out your values you think oh I
still don't feel comfortable because
that was a value so it's not as simple
as it looks but it's doing it step by
step and that's why I try and when I
work someone take them through a course
and say let's just Define values first
then we'll test you using them then I'd
come in and say let's look at collisions
in values let's look at hierarchies
let's look at modification it's a course
you're learning to refine it bit like
learning a
language yeah and this finding
fulfillment stuff is seems Seems tricky
yes yeah it does it does but again um
I'm jumping around a bit here but you
know get a sense of humor like don't
laugh at yourself and say hang on don't
take it too hard yeah the end of the day
go out and just look at the sky and be
happy you know don't get so heavy that
you you're so
analytical you strangle yourself yeah
you know that's
counterproductive Steve I think that's
that's a great place to end this thank
you so much um any final uh words of
wisdom or recommendations for anyone
who's listened to the last two hours of
this and has gotten all the way through
yeah um
I think at the beginning I said it was
self-evident if you get in a good place
then obviously you're better with
yourself and everyone around you
everyone benefits is how you get in that
good place I came in as someone a bit
left failed into this uh and saying this
is the way I feel I can work with people
it's not for everyone but I would say if
people agree that are listening find a
model or therapy or something that works
for you and then work on it all I've
been saying everyone in the field saying
the same get yourself in a good place
how you do it it's up to you just make
sure it's something that resonates with
you and is constructive but that's all
I'm asking people stop in their tracks
and think hang on step back don't spend
your life and then end up you know at
the end of your life looking back
thinking why or why or why whatever
stage you're at in life it's always good
to stop and think hang on let me look at
the bigger picture fantastic and then if
someone's gotten through this and they
want to find out more about your work um
what's like who would you recommend go
through a path through the jungle if
someone resonates they can have a look
at it um a path through the jungle is um
a course it's what I wrote Because I
thought people wanted something that was
um something they can follow chew over
and take time on so it's a quite a big
book yeah um but I was expecting like I
said earlier to be over a year uh
roughly but people sometimes go quick
but I would recommend if you resonate
with this do the exercises and take your
time don't rush um if you want to work
with people in your resonate then we do
as I'm not trying to promote we really
need to help people but we do do it uh
an eight Workshop series online so you
can do it online and join about 20 or 30
people with a mentor who'll take you
through this and highlight the points
and give you work to do in discussion
because some people like to reflect with
others yeah so but as said this there's
a lot of stuff online that people could
do individually and there's a lot of
stuff we run like conferences and fun
stuff uh we have fun and Weir days we've
got one coming up uh a Dracula hunt say
no more go online if you're interested
it's on our website but it was just to
show people life's about fun as well as
learning you know um it's not all about
being very therapeutic and analytical
get a sense of humor brilant we'll put
links to everything down in the video
description or in the show notes
wherever you're watching this Steve
thank you so much thank you all right so
that's it for this week's episode of
Deep dive thank you so much for watching
or listening all the links and resources
that we mentioned in the podcast are
going to be linked down in the video
description or in the show notes
depending on where you're watching or
listening to this if you're listening to
this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the iTunes
Store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full HD or 4k on
YouTube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching uh do hit the
Subscribe button if you aren't already
and I'll see you next time bye-bye